burning man 2022 is coming up at the end
of this month
what do you need to know to be ready and
what are the best ways flow artists can
participate in the week-long event here
are my tips and best practices drex here
from drexfactor poi sharing with you the
love of poi spinning and flow arts to
benefit your body and brain i went to
burning man for 12 solid years between
2006 and 2017 and i got to see and
experience a lot of flow out there some
of it was awesome some of it was cool
and some of it was kind of cringe
what do you need to know to have a good
time out there as a flow artist
that's what i want to help you out with
here before we dive in though i just
want to give a quick shout out to the
friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard les machinski and
becca beckham thank you all so very much
for your support from my work and my
mission if you've never heard of it
before burning man is a week-long
festival and arts event that happens out
in the nevada desert several hours
outside of reno that is centered around
creating spaces for art inclusion and
expression the majority of the events
performances and art that can be found
there are crowdsourced from the event's
more than 70 thousand attendees and flow
arts is one of the major mainstays for
participants it's where i was first
exposed to the flow arts a decade and a
half ago and it still has a special
place in my heart by the way if it's
your first time here please make sure to
subscribe and leave a like so that
you're the first to know when i drop a
new video in the future now i do want to
state from the jump that i will not be
attending burning man this year i have
unfortunately lost a lot of my
enthusiasm for the event over the years
due both to just burn out from having
attended for so many years in a row and
also realizing just how many bad actors
there are operating in the community
right now if you want a full rundown of
why i'm not going to burning man and why
i don't know when or if i'll be going
back i'll link to a vlog i did last year
on the topic down in the description or
up in the cards if you're watching on
youtube but in the meantime people are
still going to be headed out there and
they're going to have questions fire is
a big part of the experience
it is in the name of the event after all
and it's helpful to try and give people
the resources they need to be safe as
they're spinning out there in the desert
so even though i'm not going i still
want to provide helpful resources for
those who do if you want to connect with
other flow artists explore the art both
with and without fire and contribute to
a healthy flow community at this event
then let's dive in i also do just want
to outline that lots of people who
attend the event think that it's about
getting to do whatever you want free of
rules or restraints and that's not a
philosophy that i adhere to
i think healthy communities are born out
of creating and respecting mutual
boundaries and the tips i'm outlining
here will reflect that belief so first
up as a flow artist what should you
bring with you hopefully you already
have all the obvious stuff for the event
in mind goggles dust mask sunscreen a
gallon of water for every day that
you're at the event enough food to last
you the week and hopefully a shaded
place to keep whatever you're sleeping
in there will also be lots of chances to
flow out there so make sure to bring out
your props but also bear in mind that
the environment out there is brutal
there's basically no humidity and the
alkaline dust in the blackrock desert is
corrosive it's not a place for either
the faint of heart or for delicate props
if you have props that are more
temperamental or maybe have a component
on their last leg
it might be a better idea to leave them
at home most parts of your props are
going to come back to life as soon as
you get back to a more stable climate or
run them through a wash
plastic and silicone almost always come
back in more or less good shape cloth or
rope can be a different matter though
while you're out there your tethers will
pick up the dust and likely become more
abrasive than usual
make sure to bring some athletic tape
and band-aids for when that happens and
the tethers are also likely to remain
just a little extra worn after you bring
them back
just a thing to bear in mind if you're
able bring props both to spin yourself
as well as to share with others one of
the great joys of burning man is getting
to hang out with people that are eager
to try out new things so you might get
somebody new into the flow world
daytime led and fire props all have
their place at the event all are welcome
and you'll definitely find uses for
nearly anything you bring out but do
bear in mind that the ply both giveth
and it taketh away
lots of things grow legs at burning man
so don't bring out any prop that you
can't afford to lose and because we're
in the era of the smartphone here's a
huge and very important tip the moment
you get on playa put your phone in
airplane mode and stick it inside a
ziploc bag that'll keep the dust out and
you can still use the touchscreen
through the bag take it out if you need
to in order to record video but make
sure to return to the bag as soon as
possible by the end of the week you will
thank me for this tip cool so you've got
your props how do you find your people
out there one great way is to attend
workshops this is also a great option if
you're flow curious and would like to
try them out there's usually several
different camps that offer workshops on
different flow arts props but my
favorite is probably vulcan empire a
camp with whom i once stayed for several
years myself the camp is run by flo
artists and the whole concept behind it
is to give flo a home on playa vulcan
empire is located at 6 30 in g this year
that means it'll be located several
blocks behind center camp i'll link to
their instagram and facebook page down
in the description hopefully they'll
post a schedule of their workshops
before the event itself on either
platform and if not just run by and say
hello as soon as you get a chance to
unplay it and get a look at their
offerings
if you're more interested in
unstructured opportunities to meet up
with other flow artists you can always
swing by center camp during the day
there's a rotating and ever-changing
crew of people doing a variety of
different physical activities there
you'll likely run across other flow
artists and may also get introduced to
acro yoga capoeira or any number of
other fun activities that you can
cross-pollinate interest with and you'll
almost certainly run into other flow
artists at the sound camps music almost
always attracts people with props so if
you're exploring and hear something that
you like more than likely you'll find
another flow artist whose ear got
tickled by the exact same tunes speaking
of if you are deep in the music scene at
burning man you'll want to look up the
rockstar librarian this is a schedule of
major music sets at the event so if
there's someone you're dying to see play
out there this is the guide that's going
to help you plan out your week around
that again i'll link to it down in the
description it hasn't been released for
this year just yet but it should be
posted around a week or so out from the
event there are also likely to be other
spin jams and perhaps even prop making
workshops at burning man itself so when
you get there you'll be given a book
called the what where when that lists
events on playa that have been planned
out in advance
go through it on your first day and see
where and when the flow events are
scheduled for cool so that covers a lot
of the general stuff now i want to get
specific and specifically
i want to get into fire once again fire
is a cornerstone of burning man so much
of the art there is centered around fire
and as such fire dancing is a popular
activity there in the evenings
let's once again start by talking about
equipment here i would strongly
recommend taking a safety blanket with
you to the event and out to any fire
based activities you do on playa
there are loads of good options out
there including aramid blankets
duvetynes and in a pinch you can always
just use a soaked towel if you intend to
spend fire it is considered polite to
bring fuel fuel is expensive and only
becoming harder to get so one of the
biggest ways that you can contribute to
any fire related activity you do out
there is to bring a can of fuel with you
it's also really helpful to have a dip
can the best option for this the classic
empty paint can they can be easily
sealed are easy to carry and are one of
the harder options to knock over in
order to avoid spills lots of people
like ammo cans but i found out the hard
way that they don't handle the desert
conditions very well between the lack of
humidity and the corrosive dust you wind
up with cracks in the gasket that lines
the lid and it essentially becomes
useless i've had situations where i
filled up an ammo can for the night
strapped it down to my bike rack rode
out to a sound camp and discovered when
i got there that half of the fuel had
leaked out onto the playa due to
jostling around on the uneven terrain
and fuel easily able to leak out of that
cracked gasket as it was sloshing around
bottom line stick with the classic here
please next up i know you're eager to
show off that amazing costume but if
it's made of synthetic fibers
please don't wear it in the fire circle
cotton wool leather these are our
go-to's just because you're on playa
does not mean that the laws of physics
stopped working so now let's talk about
the kinds of activities and events that
you can participate in that involve fire
out at burning man because
there are a lot of them starting with
fire jams fire jams are dedicated fire
events that are made specifically for
fire dancers so generally they have a
less hectic or chaotic vibe and
equipment will be made available for
people there to use
that means these events are generally
better suited to people who are less
experienced or maybe lighting up for the
very first time check the what where
when to find out who is hosting fire
jams out there and when
vulcan empire usually hosts one on
wednesday night if i'm not mistaken but
there will be others as well
these should definitely be your first
port of call especially if you're new to
fire spinning or to burning man itself
and then there are the fire circles fire
circles are improvised fire performance
areas that are generally created on an
ad hoc basis in a variety of different
locations such as near popular works of
art sound camps or sometimes out in the
middle of nowhere past the temple in
what we call deep playa and these fire
circles have something of a mixed
reputation because sometimes they spring
up in spots where they really add to the
vibe and other times they create
dangerous and unpredictable situations
depending upon where when and how they
are created best practices if you want
to create a fire circle near some art
ask the artist before setting up
sometimes there are events planned there
that you might be in the way of or
perhaps there's something in their piece
that has sensitivity to high
temperatures that you might want to be
conscious of consent is the 11th
principle
if you're going to set up at a sound
camp try to do so on the edge rather
than the middle of the crowd people that
go to the sound camps have a high
likelihood of being on controlled
substances and may not have a good
awareness of potential dangers in the
area around them to say nothing of the
fact that there is nothing that makes a
packed crowd more dangerous than packing
them into an even tighter space
i know you want to be closer to the
action but without a designated space
set aside for spinning fire
this really quickly gets into a
dangerous place and people can
absolutely be douche bags out there
i've nearly gotten into fist fights with
people who refused to be told no even
when they were entering areas that were
incredibly dangerous for them which
brings me to another point
i can just about guarantee if you spin
at a fire circle near sound camp you
will encounter somebody who is
belligerent and or aggressive
it can be hard when someone is coming at
you but try to use de-escalation tactics
hear what they have to say do not
escalate your responses be firm but not
aggressive and also
know when to walk away sound camps can
also be kind of hard because if say a
fire circle starts early in the evening
and the crowd grows over time you might
have set up in a spot that was perfectly
fine hours before but as you get to peak
hours is now too deep into the crowd to
be safe
know when to move when it's in
everybody's best interest and again
be chill and use de-escalation tactics
when appropriate
everyone's out there to have a good time
but let's be real
nobody bought a ticket to watch you spin
fire when setting up fire circles try to
make sure all the fuel and dip cans are
put together in one spot
one point of failure is better than
several and it's a lot easier to try and
get people not to walk through one spot
than it is many also please take a turn
safetying in the fire circle
there will be times in the evening when
everybody wants to jump in at once and
the circle will get really packed and
chaotic
be the person who's looking out for the
safety of others rather than the person
who's willing to jeopardize the safety
of others just so you can have a good
time and hey if all of that sounds like
a lot of drama
that's because it can be
you can also opt to go spin led props as
you listen to your favorite music
and that's okay too less dangerous takes
up less room and you don't need to bring
extra equipment for it
this is a great option that i really
wish more people embraced regardless of
how you go about engaging in fire or
flow arts out on playa please don't moop
this is burner jargon for littering and
it stands for matter out of place lots
of small objects can easily be forgotten
or left behind the caps of empty fuel
cans the rubber bands holding together
the led cartridges of your props or the
batteries that you were trading out of
different devices
always do a moop sweep before you leave
an area find something you didn't leave
awesome do a quick check and see if
anybody in the area left it and needs it
and if not take the initiative and take
care of it yourself this makes for a
cleaner and happier playa
and if you want to see some of the most
talented fire performers on playa many
of the sound camps host a roster of
artists that they recruit specifically
to elevate the musical shows that
they're hosting
some of them have open calls for
performers so look around for
opportunities to sign up for them but
without a doubt the biggest showcase
fire dancing gets at burning man is fire
conclave
this is a collection of fire performance
groups from all over the world that
spend months preparing choreography to
perform for the entire playa in the
run-up to the titular burning of the man
effigy at the center of the event on
saturday night don't miss out on seeing
this because it's incredibly inspiring
and the thing that made me want to learn
how to spend fire in the first place
want to join fire conclave
that's a topic for a whole other video
so leave me a comment and let me know if
you'd like to see me explore that topic
once you get home your props will
definitely be covered in dust
if you can run any components that are
wash safe through a dishwasher silicone
shells or polycarbonate housings are
probably fine to wash but definitely not
the electronics themselves your fire
props are gonna be really gross you can
clean them off as best you can with a
wet wipe or burn off a lot of the crud
by having a fire jam after you get home
above all else be kind be safe have fun
and enjoy getting to meet kindred
spirits flow arts is a cornerstone of
burning man culture and a great way to
contribute to the event
enjoy the dust this video would not be
possible if not for the wonderful
support of all of these amazing people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
helped make this video and all the
videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies
so help me do it head on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of rewards and
help me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to learn more about burning man and
its intersections with flow arts culture
i have a playlist of videos on the topic
that i'll link to down in the
description or up on screen if you're
watching on youtube also the youtube
algorithm thinks you'll like this top
video here too so you might want to give
that a look as well
thank you so much for watching make sure
to get out and flow today and i'll see
you with a new video on wednesday
peace